it's a home opener 2020. the mariners
they've done well home opener 27-16 all
the time they won six of the last seven
10 and six after opening on the road
five and four versus open 2-2-2 ramone
got on and missed taiwan walker gets two
quick outs as for his punch-out of the
night here's the wind-up and the one-two
pitch it is strike three called he got
him looking with a slider on the inside
corner champion is caught looking
and that'll in the inning a nice start
for taiwan walker with a couple of
strikeouts no runs jp crawford leads off
bought over the first for the mariners
02 pitch breaking ball wave debt good
pitch over the outside corner crawford
strikes out and here is designated
hitter tim lopes one suit pitch is swung
on and missed a foul tip held by murphy
and a good start for mania back to back
strikeout and olson leads off for the
ace top of the second
and the pitch to mata left-handed hit a
breaking ball and it's spanked right to
the first baseman a well-hit ball but
right into the glove of the first
baseman evan white
banaya looks in ready the wind-up and
the 2-2 on the way swing and a miss at
that slider for strike three
and there's two outs
looks into nola and here comes the 2-2 a
little slider at the knees freezes
murphy's gone to looking third k for him
the always dangerous marcus simeon 2-2
pitch swung on and missed slider and a
beauty taiwan gets out of a little bit
of trouble here in the third inning here
comes the
the payoff
kemp at second base easy play and mania
has got nine up and nine down look at
the fourth
way of life a swing and a liner to right
center that's a bastion it's in the
alley between moore and lewis it's all
the way to the wall moriano digs the
second lewis plays it back in and ramon
stands there opening the fourth inning
with a double
loud off the bout for loriano as he
becomes the first
man to collect a base sit in tonight's
game
big time
one hopper right back to taiwan he
snares it lauriano stranded 90 feet away
he remains scoreless
another payoff from mania
how about this not even chapman can get
to that one j.p crawford living on base
once again first base runner tonight for
the mariners
there's kyle lewis a nine-game hitting
streak due to curve laced towards short
over that of simeon in the alley and
left center field
crawford is on his way to third base and
he'll get there as the throw comes into
second and the mariners are threatening
with runners in first and third for kyle
seeger
fairball inside the back passed olson's
glove into right field the mariners
strike first crawford scoring kyle lewis
being waved in piscotti finally gets it
out of the corner kyle seeger stands up
but second he brings in a pair it's two
nothing mariner to the bottom of the
fourth
chapman charging
and not in time it gets away from olson
seeger coming down he scores a headlong
slide it's three nothing mariners
down to chapman
and chapman throws that low skipped
ball over to first base olson can't
handle it
and it allows kyle seeger who alertly
continues to hustle right on through
robbie grossman to lead things off he
does a wonderful job for us here's the
pitch on the way strike three called on
grossman another strikeout for taiwan
walker that is strikeout number five
the wind-up and the 2-2
it is a strike three called they made
the appeal down to the first base umpire
who made the call bill miller on the
check swing so another strikeout for
taiwan that is
number six
there's the pitch
swing and a miss by murphy for strike
three in taiwan walker strikes out the
side here in the bottom of the fifth
inning holy smokes the mariners have
dylan moore on it third and j.p crawford
swinging a hot bat here at the start of
the year he's on at first base with one
out
when dalkin grabs it
throws it away and everybody's set his
throw to second base was wide high
run scores and the ace got nobody
and they have runners on at first and
second with one out and that'll bring up
kyle lewis
the payoff
dezi's getting nervous
here comes crawford steaming around
third six straight multi-hit games for
kyle lewis
he tacks on another it's five nothing
mariners
here's matt olsen
strike three called taiwan walker
cooking tonight eight strikeouts he has
been brilliant what a job tonight for
taiwan walker so here's simeon comes set
and throws to marcus swung on a fly ball
right center field deep in the alley
long run for moore the right fielder he
can't get it over his head and go into
the wall biscotti is scored kemp is on
his way to third and turning third he
will come to the plate and score on a
triple to right center by simeon and the
azer alive last hope for the a stephen
piscotti
the one two
out to the gap in right center de la
moore puts a squeeze on it and the
mariners get the win in game one danny
nice way to open up the 2020 home
schedule